et maintenant jacques haïti les ouistes
well as
tiens lewis bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
comme un bon moment
oui les minecraftiens assez votre
interprète oui exact d'accord jerry
lewis
acteurs réalisateurs inventeur du
téléthon merci d'avoir choisi tout le
monde en parle
[Applaudissements]
est ce que est ce que vous êtes content
d'être à paris à l'homme tous bien basse
1 from maison mon deuxième foyer nom
vous dit jerry lewis quand je suis aux
usa et que je commence à cafarder la
seule chose qui me remonte le moral
c'est de prendre un avion et d'aller à
paris oui quand je deviens saint algue
est riche et que je suis dépressif iron
air france air france tout paris et je
viens à paris
merci m
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial sourit le compte céli ce
que les victimes espéraient tennis payer
je veux tennis cueilleurs big ten espère
annoncer
alors thierry lewis en france vous êtes
une star depuis les années 60 que vous
étiez encensé par la critique la
critique intellos des cahiers du cinéma
et de la revue positif
c'est pareil en europe c'est pareil au
japon c'est pareil en australie comment
expliquez vous que vous soyez moins aimé
aux usa que dans le reste du monde
victoire qui ne sont pas intelligents
alors thierry vous aimait beaucoup la
france la france vous aime beaucoup mais
que pensez vous de la position française
sur la guerre en irak
a.ayew not get into parti il ne parle
jamais de politique
microsoft du g 10 défaites j'en faisais
déjà de la comédie c'est pas la peine
d'en faire plus d'accord
[Applaudissements]
itunes 9 bis a sonné à ce bouche alors
que vous avez donné beaucoup de plaisir
au cinéma jerry lewis et en ce qui me
concerne avec docteur jerry and mister
love aia ce extraordinaire quand il est
transformé et qui sort et que on le voit
pas nous on voit les gens qui le regarde
et on sait pas quelle tête il a c'est la
première fois que moi j'ai pris
conscience de ce qu'était la réalisation
au cinéma
dino les plus fastes was my love
c'était sa façon de montrer l'amour
qu'ils avaient from d'amour tout bien
frappé la machine tout est de damas et
des souks du rideau de fer tout ensemble
vous avez donné également beaucoup de
plaisir dans le film avec robert de niro
le film de martin scorsese ce qui
s'appelle la valse des pantins kings of
comedy bien sûr mais ce qu'on savait pas
c'est que vous souffriez le martyre hier
pendant 37 ans tous les jours vous avez
souffert pendant 37 ans way up i phone
ou crazy physique à la main et nect de
cotone comes down to mène à tout et me
to back to my du racing
voilà ce qu'ils disent est que quand il
était sur scène pendant deux heures ils
avaient l'adrénaline qui lui donnait de
l'énergie
mais dès que le rideau tombe et il avait
besoin de deux personnes pour le ramener
dans sa loge
oui oui alors c'est dû au fait que vous
faisiez vos cascades vous-même orient
always toujours l'une mois oui mais
voilà
voilà est la spécialité de jerry lewis
était de tomber de sa hauteur en de
piano de bus piano un forum aux fans
n'ont toujours sur sa colonne vertébrale
voilà alors on va regarder quelques
chutes magique de jerry lewis
puis ce jeu c'est magnéto serge manière
dont cierges
yes yes we can be
[Musique]
ici
oh
[Musique]
jerry lewis et beaucoup tombé du fait le
lot
jusqu'au jour où le 20 mars 1965
jerry lewis explose deux vertèbres dans
le bas de la colonne vertébrale en
atterrissant sur un câble métallique et
à deux millimètres près votre colonne
vertébrale était foutu il a été paralysé
pendant 27 heures votre photo de sa
venue à gué dargaud band propose pendant
37 ans pour sortir du lit on va vous
montrer
when do
térisse a baigné à l'époque des figures
on vous donne des pilules et vous
devenez accro aux antidouleurs et au
perco dans à cette époque là vous
devenez un toxicomane bien ce gars là où
il y en avoir plus
quand vous ne travaillez pas vous êtes
assis sans bouger
1 1 et à l'époque vous avez des ulcères
à l'estomac à cause de l'abus de
médicaments et des ongles longs et là
vous envisagé le suicide comme une
délivrance
yes un jour il avait un revolver
il a voulu se flinguer ayasse n'diaye et
mayotte
il a entendu sa fille sa petite fille
jamie lee en jeu c'est dany bon oeil ou
du oui ça fait je dis papa qu'est ce que
tu fais un régal away with the big boss
à houston usa garmin macho il avait un
pistolet dans son show et il a dit à sa
fille qu'il était en train de répéter
en fait il voulait vraiment se suicider
pour nous et là effectivement vous avez
trouvé un système qui s'appelle la
neurostimulation alors ces deux
électrodes qu'on met sur la colonne
vertébrale
1 et puis à l'intérieur de l'abdomen
vous avez un petit pays smucker dans le
ventre et vous avez une télécommande
alors ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
qu'avec sa télécommande quand il a mal
il règle son pacemaker qui envoie des
ondes sur les deux électrodes qui sont
sur la colonne vertébrale il aligna
routier à la douleur
et la une et johann schneider-ammann
traîneau et les élections non mais les
chaînes bien là vous êtes en train de
stimuler le pacemaker que vous avez dans
le ventre
elle na no pain no pay as you go pay buy
in one two hours est pas une idée voilà
donc il était obligé de temps en temps
comme ça de redémarrer son pacemaker qui
travaille sur les électrodes qui sont
sur la colonne vertébrale
[Rires]
il ya combien de temps que vous avez ça
trieuse deux ans à wanted to exact le 21
avril ça fera deux ans exactement où ils
utilisent ça et pourquoi vous n'avez pas
utilisé avant is now back ne savais pas
que ça existait many people do not know
about the disease
il dit que la douleur chronique est une
maladie silencieuse
oui à people want sex appeal à un
sixième de la population française un
square était ademe ou l'autre une
douleur chronique
c'est buntin éoliennes friendship au 17
mai oui américain a dit que c'est pas
seulement en irak mais c'est de l'espoir
oui oui oui nous on n'a pas ça en france
we do ritter quoi alors je ne sais pas
si je faisais docteur climatologues
vous connaissez la mer' aux stimulations
mormeck je ne connais pas la
neurostimulation pour une raison d'abord
c'est que ici rien à l'aller le la la
prise en compte de la douleur c'est
quand même assez récent ça date d'à peu
près une dizaine d'années après le
combat de deux médecins comme françois
bourreau ça ne s'invente pas qui s'est
battu françois bourreau qui s'est battu
pour faire reconnaître cette douleur
faut savoir que notamment sur les
prescriptions de morphiniques il a fallu
vraiment le combat de bernard kouchner
d'autres ministres de la santé pour que
ça passe et ça a été très difficile
like the doctor comme beaucoup de
docteurs aux états unis ne connaît pas
la neurostimulation bicross et des zones
it when kyung ho parce que ça n'a que 20
ans d'existence in technology et dans la
technologie d'aujourd'hui twilight five
minutes 20 ans c'est comme ça tous les
docteurs découvrir ça y est voilà alors
tiré
pourquoi vous avez cette fleur là haut
mais flower nikos hybrid friend ou à
l'abri match là mais avec lui un ami
qu'il aime beaucoup de best comédie
française habitante qui est un des
meilleurs comiques français avoir tout
ici à gauche un bruit de me and see you
yeah vitesse
bonsoir game to my friend pierre
aguillon royaume cinq bons amis vous
avez été un des premiers en france à à
célébrer le talent de jerry lewis
à l'époque effectivement où il a été
découvert par les cahiers du cinéma par
la revue positif et c'est vrai que c'est
la france avec benayoun aussi c'est la
france qui a été le premier pays à
rendre hommage au talent de jerry lewis
est vrai que les autres il avait dit un
jour
l'herbe est plus verte ailleurs ça c'est
vrai je dois dire que non c'est vrai que
quand j'ai rencontré de gérer ça a été
un bonheur indicible c'est à dire qu'au
premier jour j'ai senti quelqu'un avec
qui j'étais complètement en accord
il est venu vers moi et m'a tendu les
bras il était venu à paris pour tourner
boing boing je crois à l'époque et il a
voulu me recevoir parce qu'il avait vu
mon âge mes films et il m'a reçu donc
dans son hôtel et m'a tendu les bras et
m'a dit je te connais et c'est vrai qu'à
cet instant j'avais le sentiment que
nous nous connaissions depuis longtemps
beaucoup de gens m'ont dit vous êtes si
différents et moi je pense qu'on est si
proche au contraire parce que les gens
ne voient que les apparences c'est
toujours l'arbre qui cache la forêt
[Applaudissements]
votre fils est là aussi nous sommes une
vidéo non ma décision il ya aussi bien
que marraine de mailhac à venir anthony
[Musique]
ok oui messieurs merci merci beaucoup
alors vous êtes né en 1926 à newark dans
le new jersey votre père s'appelait
daniel levy tx10 dany lévis et votre
mère ça plairait rothberg alors vos
parents étaient des comédiens sur scène
dans ce qu'on appelle le bortsch circuit
tu sais quoi le mort c'est quoi le baril
à new york ce type web people us to go
fort de sa main c'est les montagnes du
quatre îles au nord de new york où les
gens allaient passer l'été au men women
s p tsx
voilà et et vos parents joués sur scène
dans ces endroits là des choses fight
night à 8,1
il faisait des choses sans une nuit par
ford qui faisait des choses cinq jours
par semaine
quand vous avez commencé sur scène vous
faisiez brodeur new world as we you
remember date
yes vous souvenez de sa merveilleuse des
deux prochaines can et mainstream one
[Applaudissements]
news
johnson and johnson j j
ouais
voilà c'était thierry lewin chanter à
l'âge de 5 ans sur scène quand il était
l'été dans les quatre îles avec ses
parents brothers can use père d'anne
c'est-à-dire brossard est ce que tu peux
me donner un 10/10 hans quoi parce que
parce que l'airé louer dans les chemins
de fer était terminée il avait plus
d'argent est ce que tu peux me donner
dix ans
c'est ce que vous êtes chanter merci
merci beaucoup aux vaincus en 1939 il
nineteen sortie nine à l'âge de 13 ans
il vous avait été exclu du collège parce
que vous avez battu le directeur du
collège se bat bien parce que vous avez
fait une remarque antisémite williams et
patrick aux twingo mais il est tombé par
la fenêtre
vous avez dit
vous avez dit ray lewis l'antisémitisme
c'est une maladie comme l'alcoolisme
yes ce n'est pas un meeting dead folio
faire leurs devoirs
c'est une maladie comme le racisme
robert bibeau annamites j'aime mon coeur
est ouvert à tout le monde
you get your life radio one de traverser
la vie adrian mannarino when you wait
si vous traversez la vie d'une façon
magnifique si vous aimez les gens et
vous étant d'en faire si vous ne les
aimez pas
alors que ray lewis pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme et perpétuer la mémoire
de la shoah en 1972 vous allez faire un
film qui s'appelle le jour où le clown
flora oui vous vous êtes à la fois
acteur et réalisateur
si une histoire extraordinaire c'est
l'histoire d'un clown allemande
anti-nazie arrêté par la gestapo et
emmené dans un camp de la mort
hélas ce clown est chargé par les nazis
d'emmener les enfants à la chambre à gaz
en les faisant rire pour qu'ils se
rendent pas compte de ce qui leur arrive
il dit qu'il le finira un jour oui parce
que ce film n'est jamais sortie n'est
jamais fini non point pour des raisons
sordide de raisons de droits des raisons
d'argent raison de production des
raisons d'argent
comme cela arrive parfois que le
producteur s'en va avec la caisse mais
un n'a pas fini d'espérer de pouvoir un
jour récupérer les pellicules et le
dernier le terminer quand vous avez vu
le film de bellini qui s'appelle la vie
est belle
est ce que vous pensez qu'il avait été
au courant de votre projet rigole forme
il était très proche de votre idée quand
même
[Applaudissements]
jerry lewis on a vu que vous allez bien
vous avez beaucoup mieux on va vous
faire une interview check up
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel est l'homme politique qui vous
donne des boutons non paris nobody à
longueur de temps des accords passés
d'importance qu'est ce qui vous fait
vomir dans le cinéma américain
aujourd'hui et se met à poil tout ce qui
se montre un descriptif de ne pas la
comprendre quel est le comique américain
aujourd'hui qui vous donne de la fièvre
bravo liasse de gradignan youtube au
sujet de quelques milk américain
voudriez vous être amnésique
nobody owens
je suis très heureux je ne vous rendez
vous à vis des femmes
la dernière fois que votre coeur s'est
arrêté de battre c'était pour qui pour
moi il fait madore pour sa femme et sa
fille emerson ayant sun
[Applaudissements]
la dernière fois vous avez eu des larmes
dans les yeux de simone et wok meilleur
tour
ils l'ont réveillé trop haut trop tôt ça
vous fait mal quand vous voyez des
jeunes qui connaissent pas vos films
costa n'ont pas d'état et quand on vous
prend pour l'animateur du téléthon ça
vous fait de la peine ouais pourquoi tu
dijk ayad donne du temps à l'automne
mais j'ai fait le téléthon à la braise
dionne nine hundred million $ et gégé
j'ai ramassé habillons 900 millions de
dollars
oui c'est vrai qu'une scène amy teibel
bras gros donc ils peuvent dire ce
qu'ils veulent moi j'ai fait ce que
j'avais à faire
ça vous fait mal quand vous réalisez que
beaucoup de vos amis sont morts
dragon quest qu'une fois ue ok ok i'm
itno j'ai besoin de savoir à sedan au
stop de choses à apprendre que you try
to get me to be n'acheter est-ce que tu
essayes de me vendre mauvais non would
you like to be as soon as bopp beach st
voulait que je sois canada je ne peux
pas faire ça james orbach m c'est pour
ça que tout mes réponses très drôle et
même i-care j'aime je peux je prends
soin d i du web des niayes can't make
the world oif
je fais tout ce que je peux paris aubry
goodman je suis à nancray beau jeu tu y
es fâché avec dean martin à la à la fin
de sa vie we are sur l'afficheur monica
on a une relation formidable quand il
est mort je ne peux toujours pas
imaginer qu'il soit mort shariff aguak
ndiaye d'optique bas et aussi je
travaille et que je suis occupé je ne
pense pas assez comme ça mais ce n'est
pas ce que veulent les matches parce que
je joue il me manque terriblement
mais à un moment vous avez été fâché
et
thiers et lewis merci beaucoup
non
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu